عشرات القتل والجرحى سقطوا في مدينه
ذنيبرا الاوكرانيه نتيجه سقوط صواريخ
روسيه على مبنى سكني مؤلف من تسعه طوابق
في هذه المدينه الواقعه شرق البلاد ولا
تزال عمليات الانقاذ والبحث عن ناجين تحت
الانقاذ مستمره
فتلاقى تقارير من ديبرو على مدار الساعه
تستمر عمليه ازاله الانقاذ هناك والقيام
بجميع الخدمات الضروريه حتى الان مصيره
اكثر من 30 شخصا يفترضوا انهم كانوا في
منازلهم ساعه سقوط صاروخ الارهابيين لا
يزال مجهولا كما انقاذه العشرات من تحت
الانقاض
الرئيس الروسي الذي مربوط نعتبر من جهته
ان كل شيء يسير وفق خطط وزاره الدفاع
وهيئه الاركان العامه وتحدثت قياده الجيش
عن ضربتها الصاروخيه على انها انجاز عسكري
في الرابعه عشر من كانون الثاني يناير تم
تنفيذ ضربه صاروخيه ضد النظام القياده
الاوكراني ومشيات الطاقه المرتبطه به تمت
اصابه جميع الاهداف المحدده وتم تحقيق
الغرض من الضربه الامين العام لحل في شمال
الاطلسي قال ان بوتين بلغ في تقدير قدره
قوته المسلحه عند غزو اوكرانيا وقال ان
التعهدات الغربيه الاخيره بتسليم اسلحه
ثقيله مهمه متوقعه عن المزيد في المستقبل
القريب تصريحاته تاتي قبل ايام من اجتماع
للدول الغربيه في المانيا في العشرين من
الشهر الجاري لمجموعه الاتصال للدفاع عن
اوكرانيا التي تنسيق امدادات الاسلحه الى
كيف